did stalin believe that communism is
good not just for him but for the people
of the soviet union and the people of
the world oh absolutely i mean stalin
believed that uh
you know socialism was the be-all and
end-all of uh you know human existence
he was a true leninist and in lenin's
tradition this was uh
you know what he believed i mean that
that set of beliefs didn't
exclude other kinds of things he
believed or thought or did
but uh no the
the way he defined socialism the way he
thought about socialism you know he
absolutely thought it was the interests
of the soviet union and of the world and
in fact that the world was one day going
to go socialist in other words i think
he believed in the
eventually in the international
revolution
so given uh the genocide in the 1930s
that you described was stalin evil
delusional or incompetent
uh evil delusional or incompetent well
you know evil is one of those words
you know which has a lot of uh kind of
religious and moral
connotations
and in that sense yes i think he was an
evil man i mean he
you know eliminated
people absolutely unnecessarily he
tortured people had people tortured
he was completely indifferent
to
the suffering of others he couldn't have
cared a wit
you know that millions
uh
were suffering
and so yes i i consider him an evil man
i mean you know historians don't like to
use the word use the word evil it's you
know it's a word for moral philosophers
but i think it certainly
fits
uh who he is i think he
was delusional and
there is a wonderful historian
princeton a political scientist actually
named robert tucker who said he suffered
from
a paranoid delusional system
and i always remember that of of
tucker's writing because
uh what tucker meant is that he was not
just paranoid meaning
you know i'm paranoid i'm worried you're
out to get me right
but that he constructed
uh whole
uh plots of people
uh whole systems of people who were out
to get him
so in other words his delusions were
that there were all of these groups of
people out there
um who were out to diminish his power
and remove him and remove him
uh from his position and undermine the
soviet union in his view so yes i think
he did suffer from
from
delusions
and this had a huge effect because whole
groups then
were destroyed
by his
by his activities which he would
construct
based on
on these delusions he was not
incompetent he was an extremely
competent man i mean i think most of the
research that's gone on especially since
the stalin archive
was opened at the beginning of the
century
and i think almost every historian who
goes in that archive comes away from it
with the feeling
of a man who is enormously hardworking
intelligent uh you know with an acute
sense of politics a really excellent
sense
of um you know political
uh rhetoric
a fantastic editor
you know in a kind of agitational sense
i mean he's a real agitator right
and um of a um you know a really hard
worker i mean somebody who works morning
till night
uh a micromanager in some ways
so his competence i think was really
extreme now there were times when that
fell down
you know times in the 30s times in the
20s times during the war
where he made mistakes it's not as if he
didn't make any mistakes
but i think you know you you look at his
stuff you know you look at his archives
you look what he did
i mean this is an enormously competent
man who who in many many different
areas of enterprise because he you know
he had this notion that he should know
everything and did know everything
i remember one
uh archive dialogue it's called you know
a kind of folder that i looked at where
he
actually went through the wines
that were produced in his native georgia
and and and wrote down
how much they should make of each of
these wines you know how many you know
barrels they should they should produce
of these wines which grapes were better
than the other grapes sort of correcting
in other words what people were putting
down there so he was you know his
competence ranged very wide or at least
he thought his competence ranged very
wide i mean both things i think are the
case
you